and
yeah i mean one of the most depressing
lessons i got from 2020
is it almost it seems like in my opinion
that we over learn the lesson of our
success and not of our failures
for example like we have this narrative
in our head that
we always have the right person at the
right time during crisis
and in some cases it was true we didn't
deserve lincoln
we didn't deserve fdr we didn't deserve
we didn't deserve a lot of presidents at
times of crisis
but then you're like okay george w bush
911
that was terrible um reconstruction
andrew johnson
awful right like we had several periods
in our history
where the crisis was there they they
were called
and they did not show up and i really it
hadn't happened
in my lifetime except for 9 11 and even
then you could kind of see
that as an opportunity for somebody like
obama to come in and fix it
but then he didn't do it and then trump
didn't do it
and you realize i feel like our politics
are most analogous
to like the 1910s like all
in terms of the gilded age in terms of
that remember there's that long period
of
presence between um between
like lincoln and teddy roosevelt we were
like wait like
who's president like or or even in even
tr was like an exception where you'll
have like
calvin coolidge who like silent cow so
we're living through
cleveland that's kind of how i if i
think of us within history
i feel like we're in one of those times
we're just waiting it feels really
important to us right
now like this is the most important
moment in history but it might be
could just be a blip right 20 30 year
blip like when you think about
who was president between 1890 and 19
before
i mean yeah between like 1888
and 1910 like nobody really thinks about
that period of america but like
that was an entire lifetime for people
right like what did they
how did they feel about the country that
they were in that's hilarious
that's how i kind of think about where
we are funny to think i mean i don't
want to minimize
it but like we haven't really gone
through uh a world war ii
style crisis so like say that there is a
crisis
in like several decades of that level
right existential risks to a large
portion of the world
then what will be remembered is world
war ii
maybe a little bit about vietnam and
then whatever that crisis is
and this whole period that we see as
dramatic even coronavirus
911 even 911 uh it's like
because you can look at how many people
died and all those kinds of things all
the drama around
the war on terror and all those kinds of
things
maybe obama will be remembered for being
the first african-american president
but then like that's yeah that's
fascinating to think about
oh man even trump will be like oh
okay that guy yeah like maybe he'd be
remembered as
the first uh celebrity
i mean reagan was already a governor
right yeah so
so like the first a political celebrity
that was a
so maybe if there's more celebrities in
the future
they'll say that trump was the first
person to pave the
the way for celebrities to win oh man
yeah
and uh yeah i still i still hold that
this this era will probably be
remembered
the you know people say i talk about
elon way too much but
but the reality is like there's not many
people that are doing the kind of things
he's doing is why
i talk about is i think this era it's
not necessarily elon and spacex but this
error will be remembered by
the new the like of the space
exploration
of uh the commercial of companies
getting into space exploration
of space travel and perhaps
perhaps like artificial intelligence
around social media all those kinds of
things
this might be remembered for that but
every all the political bickering all
that nonsense
that might might be very well forgotten
one way to think about it
is that the internet is so young
yeah i think about it um so jeff jarvis
he's a media scholar i respect
he's not the only person to say this but
many others have which is that look this
is kind of like the printing press
there was a whole 30 years war because
of the printing press yeah
it took a long time for [ __ ] to sort out
i think that's where we're at with the
internet like at a certain level it
disrupts
everything and that's a good thing it
can be very tumultuous
um i never felt like i was living
through history until corona paris
like you know like until we were all
locked down i was like i'm living
through history
like this there's this very overused
cliche in dc
where every com staffer wants you to
think that what their boss just did
is history and i've always been like
this isn't history this is something
like stupid [ __ ]
bill you know whatever but like that was
the first time i was like
this is history like this right here
well i was hoping
uh tragedy aside that this i wish the
primaries happened during coronavirus
so that we right because like then we
can see
so okay here's a bunch of people facing
crisis
and it's an opportunity for leaders to
step up like
i still believe the optimistic view is
uh
the game theory of like influencers
will always be defeated by actual great
leaders
so like maybe the great leaders are rare
but i think they're sufficiently
out there that they will step up
especially in the moments of crisis
and coronavirus is is obviously a crisis
where like
you know mass manufacture of tests uh
all kinds of infrastructure building
that you could have done in 2020
there's so many possibilities for just
like bold action
uh none of that even just forget
actually doing the action advocating for
it yeah
just saying like this we need we need to
do this
and none of that like the speeches that
biden
made i don't even remember a single
speech that by made
because there's zero bold i mean their
strategy was to be quiet
and let donald trump uh
polarize the electorate polarized
electorate and hope that
results in in uh them winning
uh because of the high unemployment
numbers and all those kinds of things
as opposed to like let's go big let's go
with a big speech
it's you know that ah
yeah it's a lost lost opportunity in
some sense
you